vegas is going to be legit
gentlemen we're live you know oh sorry
you know what your look is
what you rock the vest with the suit
better than anyone
three-piece suit yeah i don't see anyone
rocking that's better than samville
sam just wears vests
the mater d in the office sam took off
his shirt he had a tattoo of a vest
on it was ridiculous he just wears
aggressive bro okay by the way
so we have a we have a guest here we do
we got to guess here today
zooby is in the house team zoops yeah
zubies and hazubi once you get in by the
way you flew from um
man i got into here last night yesterday
okay yesterday evening
um i got to the states a week ago you
got to the states a week yeah and this
is from
from so i left the uk three weeks ago
yeah
because the travel ban is still in place
so i had to go outside the schengen zone
for two weeks so i went to istanbul
stayed there for two weeks and i flew
from there to houston i spoke at the
young americas foundation annual student
event
um i spoke there on tuesday
yeah uh that went well hundreds and
hundreds of students that was really
dope
and yeah first time in florida since
1990.
and what were you doing in 1990 when you
were in florida uh i think going to
disney world
first of all let me give you the crazy
story what happens here so we're sitting
there booking team and we're trying to
figure out guess because you know
everybody makes recommendations
gerard says pat you got to get this kind
of
yeah and i say zooby he says i'm telling
you look up so i pulled him on like
zooby zooby zubi said
i've heard a name before i go online i
put youtube's i'm like
yeah of course i know this guy's story
so then 24 hours later
some guy on your twitter account says
when you're in florida you ought to go
on valuetainment and you say
uh i don't know what you said you said i
don't uh uh
i said i can't just walk in there and
announce like you know invited
vampires unannounced i said let's do it
next thing you know a thousand likes
later within 10 minutes i'm like wow
this guy's
they love this guy yeah so we got on the
calendar i'm glad we were able to make
it
underselling the way that gerard sold
zuma no no no to gerrard
you're like you got to get them yeah
awesome like you were you were a fan so
if
by any chance you don't have a manager
that represents you this guy would be a
good one if he represented to your right
he would be he would be
a low low price of 35
[Laughter]
okay so we got a lot of crazy stories to
go through
you got a lot of strong opinions you
went viral last
uh uh uh recently with something you did
you know we got stories here from
rihanna becoming a billionaire which
we'll cover
we have a story with um miley cyrus
calling out the rapper the baby saying
we shouldn't cancel him
we should educate him kanye west has got
his new uh uh
album apparently coming out which is uh
by the way i love what jamie dimon said
to elizabeth warren when elizabeth
warren says
you know all these overdraft feats are
baloney we'll cover that
record number of journalists jailed
worldwide we don't know why maybe we'll
cover that a little bit
chinese mouthpiece paid u.s newspaper 19
million dollars in ads i think it's
important we cover that
olympic gold medalist shares usa pride
following historic win
which i think everybody loved her
child-like reaction when she won
and a few other stories but i think we
start off with uh one story
that uh zubi you may not be familiar
with the story but i think by the time
we're done reading about it you'll have
some opinions on this i think i hope so
okay so there's the story of this male
rapper
identifying as female declares if you
can bring the story up so we can see it
declares
he broke female's deadlift record so
this male rapper zooby
identifying as female declares he broke
female
deadlift record this is a wqad news 8
story
okay a british rapper named zubie okay
garnered worldwide attention to march
2019 after post uh posting a video of
himself
declaring he had broken the british
women deadlift record
in the tweet zooby said that he
identified as a woman whist
lifting the weight ultimately trolling
the debate of transgender people
competing in athletic events
he claimed to have broken a woman deadly
record of 238 kilograms that's 528
pounds
and he said it was without even trying
different athletic organizations both in
the united states and around the world
have
their own policies in place to include
the
transgender athletes the international
olympic committee a national collegiate
athletic association and the naia
all have rules that say transgender
women need to pass certain tests us
powerlifting however does not allow
transgender women to compete as women so
can we play this video if you don't mind
just play the video of him doing it
because i think everybody needs to see
this this is you
look at that though damn that was a
clean lift i could have done like five
of those
four million views your tweet i keep
hearing about how biological men don't
have any physical strength advantage
over women in 2019
so watch me destroy the british woman
deadlift record without even trying p.s
i
identified as a woman lifting the weight
don't be a bigot yeah
the uh the inside grip by the way sumo
deadlift
solid yeah if gerard approves you know
it's legit so what kind of bench is what
i gave you the idea of wanting to do
this because
at one point everybody was talking about
this so we'll give you the idea no doubt
so
since like when what had been when did
the world start going
super silly like 2015 2016 i was
following these stories
and seeing this happening right this is
when new gender started being introduced
to the western world
and people could identify as anything
and i was like well this is ultimately
going to lead to
you know there's going to be downstream
repercussions of this i can see what's
happening
i saw what happened with fallon fox in
mma
and then in some collegiate areas i
think both in
the in canada and the usa i was just
seeing you know male athletes
competing against girls and women by
identifying
as the opposite gender and i said okay
you know what
if that if those are the rules let's
take this to its logical conclusion so
out of curiosity i just did a quick
google search of okay in my weight class
what's the british women's deadlift
record and
i saw it was 215 kilos i know my pb is
275.
so i was like oh okay and then i just
had that video on my phone from one of
my training sessions
of me doing pulling 230. oh so you
didn't do this afterwards
that was just from one of my training
sessions and i so i just took it i just
tweeted
at the time i had 18 000 twitter
followers i thought this is going to get
a couple retweets a couple lols
and i did not know this was going to be
the thing that would introduce me to
millions of people
all around the world i put that tweet
out there and within seconds
i knew something was up i was just
looking at my phone like
okay within think 10 minutes the video
had 10 000 views
and it just kept growing and growing it
was getting retweeted
all over the world by huge personalities
people were commenting in different
languages and for days and days and days
this thing was just going viral going
viral going viral
after a while joe rogan picks up on it
talks about it on his podcast which
gives it this whole second absolutely
boost and
i mean that was march 2019 and
some and it's gone viral several times
since then because people will pick up
again on the story plus two equals five
for two years two plus two equals
freaking five man and then of course in
the olympics now you've had uh um
this thing came came to head again right
where new zealand had their first uh
transgender weightlifter who failed
anyway but that caused a big stir so the
story sort of
is one of those things that just keeps
coming back what do you what do you
think they should do
i mean right now it's the olympics right
i mean what do you think they should do
so by the way there are some people that
you know they strongly believe they want
to be transgender sure okay so
let it be it's a libertarian mindset do
as you choose but how do you think the
olympics
should handle transgenders simple i
think
you there there's there's two options
either they kind of
lead to the same result firstly most
people don't understand that most
male sports are not actually male sports
they're just open
right but it turns anyone can compete
yeah but it turns out there's never been
for obvious reasons there's never been
it's very important to repeat what you
just said so in olympics most male
sports are open
yeah i i'm not sure about olympic
specific but most sports in general
you know i don't believe the nba the nfl
the mlb they don't have a rule saying
women are like you see these women
become like nfl kickers or even college
in youth sports in america
you know especially because women
develop faster than young boys do young
girls so like up until
as late as 12 13 years old girls soccer
players girls and boys basketball girls
and boys that's okay small girls
it just turns out that you know there's
never been a woman big and strong enough
to play in the nfl
or in the nba etc which is why you have
a woman's sports division so it's the
women's sports divisions that are
that are exclusive whereas the others
open so you just have an open category
so however you identify whatever best of
the best
and then you have a female category
simple
that's all yeah the the the interesting
thing is like look
it you're talking about a meritocracy at
the end of the day right like if
somebody's good enough like i always saw
that the the person who really could
break down a gender barrier in a sports
is a knuckleballer like a knuckleball
pitcher if there's a woman who could
throw a knuckleball you throw at 65
miles an hour it's about the movement of
the ball
the softer you throw it the more
effective it is you don't need to
overpower
that's somebody that could actually
break down a gender barrier she doesn't
need to she doesn't need to run as fast
as anybody else she doesn't need to
swing the bat
she can literally use a technique a
technical
uh pitch and be able to compete at that
level so that that would be something
but like what vanderbilt did by running
that kicker out so she could kick the
ball
30 yards out of bounds oh yeah break the
gender barriers of the sec and it was
like my god
you turned this poor girl into a show
pony that's what you did you took this
poor girl
and you told her you turned her into a
show pony for your progressive ideology
she won
she won sec special teams player of the
week
for a 30-yard kickoff out of boundaries
what's the one thing you always joke
about like
i got one year of eligibility of college
left baseball i brought up i might go
okay guys as soon as joe biden like one
of his very first uh
one of his very first executive orders
from from our
uh our king was to say no questions
asked
to to uh basically reverse what they
would call the the transgender
discrimination that trump had done
and say that no questions asked anybody
who identifies as a woman
will should be able to compete in uh
athletics ncaa athletics
uh as as their their gender identity so
i'm like okay
i could as a former professional
baseball player go back
at my age and play softball
at the university of miami with a metal
freaking bat
you're gonna let me hit a ball against
17 year old girls
who and and if i if i hit a ball up the
middle and murder a pitcher or the third
baseman is just getting
kneecapped that's okay that's equality
because god forbid you tell me
no bro you're a 34 year old man go
anywhere but here
that's that's the part that's bigotry
not me
showering with a 17 year old 18 year old
girl
in the locker room with a 17 18 year old
girl uh
you know dorming with them practicing
with them and competing against them
that's equality but if you if you
preclude me from that
well you're a bigot you know for me the
way i see it is the following why don't
you just create a
a transgender competition let them go at
it let them compete
let them go at it rather than having to
go and take things away from women if
you
if you want to create a transgender you
know
contest competition go for it i don't i
don't see anything wrong with that
where you're competing against somebody
their their argument pat is that they're
not transgender yeah you're dealing with
ideologues
did you did you hear did you hear the
uh argument navertolovo made no have you
have you heard the argument she made i
heard i'm not sure can you pull it up
can you pull up her argument she made
the uh tennis player navratilova man
that to spell that name
kai tina
so then put uh trans which puts
transgender
yeah okay transgender she said something
about that she said some quote quote
about it
uh no intention she's an art jones are
critical so
she rejects alexander translation click
on news
there's a story about this yeah i saw
that um
okay uh go back guy go back there was a
story right at the top
right there click on that i think that's
2019 well that's when it was when she
said it though go go
up uh she said something very powerful
uh and by the way navertolova is fully
supportive of gay rights well she is gay
yeah i know she is
but she said something here are you know
anyways you guys can continue i'll find
this quote here to read it to you it's a
powerful statement she made
i just have one question because quite
candidly
this is not anything that i'm like
waking up being like what are the trans
saying today this is not
like what percentage of the world are
transgender like
point zero zero one percent like a
fraction of a fraction of a factor okay
so why is this such a big deal because
they're infusing themselves into the pop
culture and sports it's because it's
been it's being forced on people yeah
absolutely
right because most people look
regardless of whether someone it
shouldn't even be political but whether
someone is
liberal conservative libertarian
whatever most people don't care if
you're an adult
do what you want to do maybe i don't get
it maybe i don't you know agree with it
whatever
but if that's what you want to do it's
not harming anyone live your life how
you want you're a man you want to wear a
dress you want to put up makeup
you know you're allowed to you can do
you can do what you want the problem
with this issue
is that they're you know and again most
most transgender people i probably know
most people don't know any i actually
know a couple
i don't know any who's in favor of this
whole sports thing right they think it's
crazy because they recognize reality so
it's just the woke left trying to
use their ideas idea laws exactly trans
are like yo we're good yeah
but this is something that would
potentially chelsea handlers yeah but
there's something that impacts 50
percent of the population
right why is it the men aren't worried
about this yeah because it's right it's
not going to affect them exactly
which ex which in itself blows up the
entire argument but
brought up fallon fox and she's
literally caving she was caving women's
faces who is she
she was a transgender mma fighter she
was a man this is the problem
was a man no became a woman and was able
to compete against other women
and cave now is it more common for women
to become mentally
can i jump in here and say that you
cannot actually change your biological
sex it's not possible
okay so even saying she you're giving in
to the argument
you're not talking about a she you're
talking about a biological male you
cannot change from a man into a woman
it's not
possible you can make yourself appear as
such you can identify as such
but it is not physically possible and i
think part of it is this overt political
correctness with people having to
you know respect the pronouns and change
their whole language
to defy reality which actually allows
people to run with these crazy arguments
because as soon as you start calling
someone a woman they're like well if
they're a woman why can't they compete
against women and i'm like well no
that's not a woman that's a biological
male identifying
as a woman why because when you're young
you go through puberty and if you're
born a boy you go through you've got the
hormones
talk about it extension bone density
it's the the
you know muscle retention i mean we're
we we are he's right we're so bilateral
there is nothing that any of us here at
this table can do
that would turn us into pam that's bad
news i thought i could it's not
yeah anybody could i mean
hold my beard who's the most famous
transgender person in the world caitlyn
jenner probably okay
so i have one quick story about this so
um
my one of my best friends is that guy
chris humphries that married kim
kardashian i was
in the wedding i walked chloe down the
aisle bruce was there
this was he knows he's been doing 2 000
just dead named
what's that you're just dead named
someone's going to cancel you oh all
right well it happened well it's called
dead naming oh because
he doesn't exist anymore but at the time
it was bruce jenner that was like tying
our tie
point is this what's your language
buddy yeah it's a money field i gotta go
there but
point is we're not gonna fast forward
this is probably
when did she
a few years ago it was probably 2017.
talk about the future governor shout out
to she did i don't think that's happened
she
came out on diane sawyer on believe like
2020 and did the whole
thing or whatever but here's the story
that night
um chris was playing for the wizards at
the time washington wizards and they had
just swept
the toronto raptors right drake was at
the game was a big deal
it was breaking news caitlyn jenner
announces because there was rumors that
was going on right and it was
you know after the game we're
celebrating sweep we're having dinner
having drinks
and this is and i was like this is some
weird [ __ ] huh and he's like
yeah like thank god i got out while i
did and i go you gotta tweet that
and he goes no hell no i go i literally
i'm like give me your phone i've never
tweeted before in my life
and i tweeted on chris's
this was me i'm owning up to it you
canceled him like thank god i got out
well i just ended his career
not so much because of the jenner thing
yeah but because look at the track
record that happened that cardet
lamar odom you know od scott disick
rehab
the father like literally died robert
kardashian hasn't been see this
song hasn't been seen in years i'm like
look at you bro your words 50 million
you just swept the
you know the uh the raptors your life's
great and he goes dude i got no ill will
towards
caitlyn but like thank god i gotta kind
of got out what i did so i took his
phone
and i tweeted it i'm like ha ha like we
did it like huh and like
dude an hour later his publicist calls
what's up
he's getting slaughtered slaughtered on
twitter
he didn't throw you under the bus though
he came out made an apology
he wasn't gonna be like my boy saws like
i could have been my phone was hacked
yeah
it literally was but he came out made an
apology and like the next
i was staying with him he goes never
[ __ ] touch my phone again oh
man but he got slaughtered this explains
in the many months that we've been with
uh adam sauce i have not seen chris
humphries not one
freaking coming yeah he'll be here
it's a very sensitive topic but it's at
least we're talking about it so respect
to what you're doing at least making it
something dude caitlyn jenner's got one
of the greatest quotes of all time too
afterwards she said in l.a it was easier
to come out as transgender than it was
to come out as a republican
oh yeah oh wow that's believable you get
you get embraced and celebrated by
you know the hyper wokies for the former
and you get denigrated for the latter so
it's not surprising especially in
california gosh
yeah it's actually shocking that you
said that because that's pretty
ridiculous that's what
it's her truth yeah let me let me let me
her truth let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question so
for me whoever you edify and lift up
people will do
what that person is doing so for example
in a
sales company for us whoever you i'll
always say you give me the number one
person of any company i'll tell you the
future the company next five to ten
years
based on who the number one is not who
number two is
who the number one is meaning no not ceo
the sales company you got you got a
thousand sales player sales
sales so sales leaders sales people yeah
but whoever the number one is anytime i
chose a number one that was more about
them than the team the company collapsed
every time but if you chose the right
number one the company
exploded like sao paulo's they took the
company a whole different level we've
had great number ones guyton sappala
we've had a lot of different number ones
right and they're all great number ones
because people want to be like
well okay can i get that kind of
recognition yes like we're about to play
we're going to vegas tomorrow we're
going to have 12 000 people i'm on the
phone last time with mario lopez because
he's hosting awards ceremony nicki james
sebastian
mike tyson it's going to be pretty
intense even next week in vegas for a
whole week at mgm grand
but whoever your number one is people
are going to duplicate so now
you go back 50 years ago in america who
was the hero in america 50 years ago jfk
okay who else yeah i'm with that john
wayne go
go 50 years ago it's actually 20 71.
1971. after that 1971 what was that
just died 1971.
who was the richest man in america in
who was it who was a cow pull it up and
see who was it was lee iacocca there you
go uh
i don't know 1971 is probably going to
be a free it has to be it has to be
forward it has to be somebody
for those guys richest man in the world
in 1970s
daniel ludwig it's an interesting story
okay so keep going frank sinatra
everybody wants to be like frank elvis
okay elvis you want to be like elvis
great who else did you want to be like
uh that's clint eastwood really getting
into uh his his uh
his john well 71 the counter culture was
really big too you were starting to get
um
i mean it was really by the way look at
that there's howard hughes so you look
at howard hughes it is
jay paul getty was prior to that okay
okay i'm thinking
one of the great chamberlain kareem
abdul-jabbar
one of the greatest independence ever
called easy rider by dennis hopper and
peter fonda and jack nicholson 1970
perfect jack nicholson was the face of
hollywood i thought was he one of the
guys
peter fond the problem okay 71. fair so
this the beatles were huge
the beatles were huge in 71. okay so if
you're 18
if you're 14 to 18 years old and you're
in high school oh my gosh
bro i'd love to be like in baseball it
was who seven you want to be
basketball was kareem 71 baseball would
be aaron
the end of medicare aaron yeah aaron
let's just say you're looking up to
mickey mountain you're looking up to
aaron right okay
so so these are the heroes we looked up
to right at that time
so kid is competing to be who that
person
okay kid is trying to be like that
person who's the hero today in america
lebron james who else well that's one of
them but
give me some of the names heroes heroes
heroes who's
some would say someone would say obama
okay someone would say
the rock give the name so let's just go
through them obama are you talking about
actors you're talking leo
you're talking uh yeah leo's a hero do
you think people look at leo like they
want to be like this
people want to wait if you're talking
about the 14 to 18
age range you got to talk about youtube
i was just about to say check okay
you gotta
yeah yeah so so let me ask you a
question let me go to a different part
here so in 1971
what does a man's man look like in 1971
manly
clint eastwood man clint eastwood john
wayne frank sinatra you know somebody
like that was a man's man and he pulled
something out you wanted to be like a
man's man
in the in the 70s right okay what does a
man's man look like today
what is a man's manta is that even an
insult to say a man's man what's a man's
mouth i think a man's man
looks similar but i don't know if a
man's man is what's being pushed to the
mainstream
if that makes sense is a man's man
likely to be on the cover of a time
magazine today is a man's man likely to
be the hero today is a man's man likely
to be someone we look up to today no no
no they they they're pr
precisely the opposite they're presented
as like being somehow repressive of
other people
like you know if you somehow are working
a lot and earning
you can't earn a good living for
yourself without somehow oppressing
somebody else
yeah they literally call it toxic
masculinity so okay so let's talk about
a rich person in 1971 if you were rich
did people want to know who the
lives of rich and famous was first was
it like oh my god
the lifestyles of the rich and famous
okay so it was cool to be rich in the
70s
what is it today to be rich i talk about
it all the time what is the thing i hate
most about our culture is the repentant
rich
but what i'm saying to you is like today
not even the repentant rich i'm talking
the 14 to 18 year old is he looking up
saying dude i admire these rich people i
want to be like
well there was a study that came out um
a poll they yeah they pulled
people under 21 their thoughts on
capitalism versus socialism
it was like shocking i think 54 percent
said that capitalism was bad and 44 said
yeah
so younger people are not advocates of
capitalism yeah but they both
i bet you most the people taking that
pull cannot define either of those and
that was actually the part b to that
is that they actually asked the
follow-up question like would you know
the difference and they're like
not really no socialism sounds i mean
the word sounds nice like
it rolls off the tongue nicely it's got
the word social in it sounds great
you know who doesn't like being social
social media capital sounds social
security yeah yeah but
but again i i think i think this is a
we've we've forgotten who the hero is
can i show you a picture we are we are
edifying the wrong hero so these kids
have the wrong
image of who to look up to because i
don't care who you admire
but i at least want to have somebody i
put up there to say
hey one day what if one day you know
this is a man's man this is an example
of one day for us to be alive i'm gonna
show you a picture because that's
actually actually a great point it's a
great i pulled this picture up
this is trending on on social media and
it's basically
back in my day this was now your
generation
exactly so i see that it's freaking
hilarious the original nas versus little
nausea listen i i actually
look there's i have an interesting
thought you actually have that out i
have an interesting thought about it see
with little nozzles
if you look at at like the people in the
like the 1700s 1800s 18th century right
these are some of the toughest human
beings on planet earth and they dressed
like that yeah
like the laws of chivalry had to be
invented because people were just
murking each other was like say
something wrong about me and we'll have
a duel
and i'd shoot you in the face but i'd
walk around looking like that
but then we'd kill each other over an
argument i think
we would have loved it i think we need
better heroes
how about we just don't need to tear
them down we forget having better heroes
yeah it would be great can we just start
by not tearing
down the heroes that we already have so
tearing down statues so yesterday uh
this week i spoke to a guy named kenny
shu
who wrote the book called the
inconvenient minority
and he talks about how there's this high
school called the thomas jefferson high
school it's a number one high school in
america
best grades kids come out there 76
percent of the school is asian
okay 77 nearly nearly 80 percent what
city is this in i don't know if you look
it up he was talking about thomas
jefferson high school
and then he talks about how in harvard
out of all the applicants that submit
their applications
they should accept 43 43 of harvard
should be asian but only 21
is because they want to make sure
they're inclusive you know the whole
you know making sure we're accepting
discriminate against they don't want too
many asians there because it's way too
much
out of 5.9 in america asian our
population is 5.9
asian 22 percent of harvard
students are asian okay so out of only
5.9
to 22 of harvard so they're just
completely rocking it right
yeah and you know he's talking about
what's going on why he didn't want to go
to harvard et cetera and yesterday i
talked to eddie gallagher i don't know
if you know eddie gallagher's eddie
gallagher is a
he's the guy that was the navy seal he
did eight tours two bronze medals and
he was seen with the video with one of
the isis terrorists that they took the
picture in the video and it went viral
he went to prison
you know this story yeah then trump uh
got him he says i don't i don't support
what he did but i think amanda put his
life out he's got to get out
and i said tell me what it's like in the
military the military has something
called the
navy and ncis okay it's like the
intelligence where they do research on
literally a tv show called nci yeah if
you can pull out what ncis means and
then there's cid
ncis and cid are the same thing i said
what role does ncis place he says
he says who runs ncis he says well it's
the officers and i said okay
so why don't officers support what
you're doing he says because
you know for them they don't they don't
like us so i went and googled i said let
me look up navy seal because when you
think about a man's band what do you
think about you think about when you if
i told you right now he's a navy seal
what would you say
how would you look at him if i told you
the navy's strong masculine brave
courageous you look at him in a
different way i look at him now he's not
a navy seal he just goes to the beach a
lot but
you know so but if i said navy seal you
immediately judge him so i looked up how
many people are navy seals in america
today 2 500.
how many active billionaires do we have
in america today around the same number
2500 okay he said ncis
hates anybody that makes it to the
highest level
like navy seals so who writes about
billionaires
that they don't like them you got
regulators like an elizabeth warren
you got some journalists that go after
them the cid
and regulators they're the same human
beings he said the most interesting
thing to me yesterday because general
miller i asked him about general milly
i said so what happened with general
miller talking about crt and here's a
general like why is a general
going out there defending some of these
things being taught he says because
there's an interesting thing that you
don't know about us so what's that
he says in the military after oh four or
oh five
to get your promotion congress has to
sign off on your promotion
let me say this one more time so if
you're a politician
politicians have to sign off if you
become a colonel
or a general one star general you need
congress
to sign off on your promotion that's
interesting this is gallagher is saying
this to me on the podcast we did yes he
has a book that just came out called
he's got a book coming out with the
interview's going to come out here next
week so
the point is the people who are not the
man's
man are in charge of building up who the
man's man is
so up until that changes we are never
going to recognize who the management is
we are never going to recognize who the
real heroes are
so the problem isn't that the problem is
who's telling the world
who the real heroes are on a small level
a much smaller level than that that's an
incredible story
and also if we can find a crossover
between the 2 500
uh navy seals under 2 500 billionaires
we have batman so if we find one that's
paul
but the the the interesting thing about
what you're saying is there's actually a
guy who listens to the show
who is pushing back on that and that's
curt schilling kurt schilling whether
you agree with him or
don't agree with him kurt schilling is a
very great uh american baseball pitcher
bloody suck
bloody sock incredible competitor tough
guy tough dude
but he made some uh to to you know
our our establishment some some
questionable tweets while he was working
for espn
and now he has requested to be taken off
the hall of fame yeah he's almost a lock
to make it this year
and he's been requested to be taken off
the ballot because he does not want to
give the writers
the the the ability to judge his career
you don't get to tell me whether or not
i was a hall of famer
he'll wait the seven years until he goes
to the veterans committee which is a
bunch of old players
that select people that that haven't
gone through the process
and he's like i would rather wait and
then have my peers put me in the hall of
fame because i respect them and if they
don't put me in
that's fine but zooby who was your hero
growing up
honestly who are some of your heroes
sure thing i was i'll start with my
parents right
which is important that's important to
say my parents um
a man uh who am i right like
uh hello cool jay okay yeah
ll cool j is bad as hell i
wrestling so i love like the rock and
stone cold
how old is it i'm 34. okay yeah
yeah you know i i yeah i was i was
really into all those guys
um a lot of i guess
rappers to some extent not in terms of
like role models
you know like my my my dad and my older
brothers and you know family for that
but in terms of the cool who were your
who were your rappers well you were your
naz person were you two
uh oh you're 34 so tech nine
um andre the three no not really
real really no um this is in the uk mob
deep
mob you were in the uk at this time yeah
i mean i wouldn't say like those people
were like heroes
i mean these are some of the artists now
let me ask you another question who did
your dad
admire who did your dad say this is uh
this is uh
who did your mom say oh my gosh this
person here
is somebody that really made an impact
who was that person to you
that's that's a big question i man i'd
need to ask my dad you're thinking about
that are you guys also thinking about it
absolutely like who was it for you like
by the way folks if you're watching this
i'm curious like somebody said here
jordan tyson gretzky stallone arnold
list is long you know nice you know
these names that are coming up
who was your hero who was your hero
actually think about it
who was yours who was your hero as a kid
growing up you're 22. so i mean
steve irwin the guy the animal guy yeah
i cried like a baby when he died wow i
don't know
why like i loved watching his tv show
yeah but he was one of the first people
that when he died like i was
i was just now let me ask you was it you
or did your mom and dad also love him
and
i think i think i probably watched it
mostly with my dad there you go okay so
there was a connection with your dad so
how about yourself who was who was your
i had one guy
it was isaiah thomas for detroit pisces
oh okay i'm really obsessed
with i was a point guard i love my dad's
from detroit he went to university of
michigan i loved isaiah thomas
and then the second person it was more
of a
not a person but a thought process i was
obsessed
with the civil war i loved the north i
loved abraham lincoln i saw the movie
glory with um
denzel washington i just sympathized
with
everything that was going on with that
and i just never understood the
confederacy i was like [ __ ] them
very important how old were you i mean i
was a kid 10 years old that's crazy so
watch what's how interesting that is
because now
you're kind of we're learning about
ourselves like it's not every day we
wake up who was my hero when i was a kid
right
who was yours maybe a movie by the way
you also went to a movie like
like for me if you think rocky 4
to me i watched rocky 4 a few hundred
times and the whole part at the end when
he says
at the beginning of this fight you know
you didn't like you know all that said
but if he
you can change if he can change if i can
change anybody can you who is yours
i mean first of all my dad is not even
close the
the the the disparity between first and
second and so so let's set that part
aside it's an unfair advantage yeah
but uh rocky would be one okay what
rocky did
and you were and i ran at the point i
was in iran at the point i'd say rocky's
prob guys i would have to tell you rocky
may be a top five
growing up as a kid i think shaw would
be on that list and that was before
you came in the rocky character the
rocky character not sylvester stallone
question for you you didn't have any
ties to america right
no not at all but you saw this movie and
you're like damn america
yeah not at all but because because my
my ties are to russia
exactly even my mother's side they're
all communists so to them
they they have ties to the communistic
regime they escaped that to come but my
mother still had affinity for them you
know my mother wanted to name me sasha
we talked about this
last week would your mother have rooted
for ivan drago in that movie
my mother would have yes she would have
definitely rooted for ivan drago so wow
so if you look at he says for me
yeah i win for me and then you come to
america and then you come to america and
you think we're your heroes i looked up
to him when michael jordan retired i
cried like a baby
when magic got aids i was devastated
when tupac
died it was like freaking you know best
friend dying
uh you know first president i shook
hands with was
clinton at glendale when i was working
at haagen-dazs and he just walked by i'm
like oh [ __ ] he rolled up dog he doesn't
know he was not he was at glendale
galleria doing a
campaign trail and he was walking on
shaking hats i put my hand out he shook
my hand i'm like 14 years old take a
double scoop
and but the point is like who did we
look up to who did mom and dad look up
to my dad looked up man's man everything
to my dad was a
john wayne my dad was clint eastwood so
you're like
i want to be a man's man one day who was
yours
uh it's a weird question for me man
because um
i was brought up differently you know
like i was brought up like
hardcore you know new york you know
you've told me you've told me before
like you had very
big admiration for ron jeremy but i'm
talking like
like heroes specifically heroes yeah uh
my dad was probably my hero but he
my dad was definitely my hero but um
you know like i i came home with a
jersey on one day and he goes
oh yeah you're going to wear another
man's name on your back what's wrong
with you bronx tale
that's that's like the bronx tale mickey
mantle don't pay your rent that's
exactly that is exactly how my father
was my father's like oh you're crying
because the mets
the meds lost okay i gotta go daryl
strawberry and payne
i'm gonna go how do you feel about that
how'd you feel about it then how do you
feel about it
it changed the way i viewed like i
didn't like i was very
uh i think it helped me compete
because it gave me an idea that these
are just men if
if they can do something i can do
something you know i i really like
there's people like i admire
their ability to do their profession but
i never really looked at them as like
heroes so other than your dad there's
nobody there like dude
like yeah but i mean there's like i as i
would read and i'd read about you know
historical figures and as you know i'm
very into politics and history and like
i'd be like this is a great man
this is a this is a great man this is a
great man who did great things
but i never really like i look at it
almost as like
i could emulate them like the this is
somebody that i i can do if he did it
this way i can do this this way as well
speaking of great men by the way
not to cut you off kai i'm shocked you
didn't say
teddy winston churchill and teddy
roosevelt teddy roosevelt
those weren't until later though
by the way here's what's interesting
some of the young guys here that i'm
looking at
a kid says david goggins great guy to
look up to
fantastic because that's a that that's a
qualified man's man right
uh easy mom may be a different story
give me that
that chuck norris that's right chuck
norris i'll tell you what it's something
i've had to kind of unlearn as i got
older because you like the the mentality
becomes like
like you see someone doing well and the
initial reaction is oh he ain't [ __ ] man
like
i screw that guy i hate her mentality
it's a hater it's a 100
hater mentality don't be a hater what
ends up happening to it is is like
yeah it's cool like you're not a fan boy
or nothing like that or is that a part
of jersey culture or yes that's for sure
okay yeah yeah i was gonna try
that for sure but there's also a part of
it where
you have to be willing and open to be
like you know what man maybe this guy
knows something i don't know and let me
let me humble myself a little bit
and let me try to learn in that moment
but it's taken me a very long time
to kind of unlearn that man that's
interesting i don't need this dude that
must be a real culture cultural thing
because i i've never
i've never had that like i finally never
have what zubi like that kind of hater
is it uk or is it your family
that's a good ques probably more family
okay probably more family like i mean i
was always brought up and i think just
the way i'm wired to you know like
admire and respect you know hard work
and
success and that's what people would
call a meritocracy etc
it was never really sort of formally put
to me that way
but that's how i always looked at it i
mean even to this day
even i like i don't hate on anyone or
anything even
with someone who i don't really like or
i don't really like what they're doing
or whatever
if someone is successful in any way
shape or form there's always something
that you can learn from that
yeah always something that you can take
away you may not even you know some
musician could blow up and you don't
even know
you don't like their music but you look
into the story of okay how did they get
there
and how did they do it and you'll you'll
pick up something even some of these i
don't know
people talk a lot these days about
influencers oh there's these people on
instagram or tick tock or whatever and
you know people criticize them because
they're like oh that girl's just you
know posting dumb dancing videos and
she's
right you know but it's like well she's
got 15 million followers she's doing
something
like addison ray you can actually you
can learn you can learn something
from that like it doesn't matter who you
are you could be a business person
absolutely
tell us about your parents stronger were
they christians
yeah my parents are christian okay yeah
so my parents are from nigeria
okay um so you know been married 40 plus
years
somewhat good a perfect combination
between
traditional values and also being open
to
the world and embracing new ideas so my
dad's a medical doctor
my mom used to be a journalist now she
works as a as a magistrate
um and i've got i'm the youngest of
youngest of five kids
and just brought up well like i've got
wonderful wonderful parents
a wonderful family which i think is the
hugest they're very lucky
yeah i think that's the biggest
privilege that people do not
talk about let alone being born in this
time frame which is one of the things
the american left is really really
strong about wanting to kind of
eliminate
no privilege privilege is a great thing
like privilege is a great thing like
i think this this inversion of privilege
to be something you're supposed to be
ashamed of and atoned for
is totally insane right like if you have
privilege like
take that and use it to your advantage
and use it to help other people
there's nothing to be ashamed of that's
that's fantastic man sometimes you
you forget just the values of how to
raise a family this guy came yesterday
applying to be a ceo of vitamin c-o-o of
entertainment
and he is from uh uh uh bahrain
is where he's from okay and he talked
about we're talking about the
crime levels in dubai okay the
conversation about dubai
they don't have guns nothing there is no
crime no crime
at all but the family values and
principles of how they raise their kids
and what they do is so high they value
respect marriage relationship all that's
so high that
you don't get a lot of that sometime
when you you said you lived in saudi
arabia for you i lived in saudi arabia
for 19 years
for 19 years 19 years that's right it's
a lot more than a year
look at saudi arabians and arenas
getting along right
they're doing it i do want to clarify
one thing if i can though because
you know i don't want it's the wrong
mentality to say that
i was brought up to be a hater oh yeah
no no no no but i just i do want to
clarify you did say that's like a jersey
thing
but it's not like i can't really explain
it if you if you didn't grow up in that
area it's not
jealousy and it's not hate it's just
like all right whatever he's doing his
own thing
like
if uh if if somebody would come home and
like my sisters would go to a a birthday
party
like colt's neck it's some like big
house or something like that and come on
they'd be like you wouldn't believe the
size
like we had like this little tiny like
above ground pool in the backyard and
stuff like that
now to my father's credit he grew up in
an apartment
complex like so having his own yard was
he he was living his dream no matter
what was in it you know what i mean so
like now this other person so my sisters
don't know
any different they could come out and
they're like well they got this big pool
and everything like that he's like hey
good for them god bless but you know
just be careful
because you know the the food they eat
don't make you [ __ ] somebody say when
you know that's and then i have a
question for you
that comparison is the thief by the way
what he's saying is very powerful a lot
of people
are raised that way somebody said here
dean martin
that was one of the people we grew up
with paulette my sister was texting me
we grew up to jerry lewis
wow and dean martin my dad loved john
wayne john wayne he loved
jerry lewis dean and jerry yeah well
comparison is the thief of joy it's the
last thing you said which is actually
true so sometimes
like i'm actually a pretty yo respect
bro like i
but i'll find myself hating sometimes
right i think it happens right like
quite candidly
and then when i find myself hating on
someone i'll say hold on
why am i hating on this person and
oftentimes
it's because they're doing something
that i want to be doing or i think i can
be doing
so i'll catch myself and say all right
rather than hating but i ain't [ __ ] just
be like all right cool recognize that
that's
something that you actually respect and
you want to do and just
pursue that rather than hate on him
because he's doing that that's the way
to do it but i think that you can't
if any kids are like listening to this i
wanna say kids like late teenagers early
twenties like
that that's maturity like that is what
you grow into that's not something
you're you're an incredibly impressive
human being if you're coming to that
mentality yeah
in your late teens early 20s like a lot
of us have to burn bridges
make mistakes and be like wake up in the
morning with the regrets and be like
damn i wish i didn't do it like that
and then use those you know use those
scabs and those scars to build the new
person you know what i mean so
my question for pbd do you ever find
yourself
hating on anybody and catch yourself
because obviously you're not a hater
you're very big on
edifying like there's i never hear you
being like ah he ain't [ __ ] i've never
heard you say like he ain't nothing
whatever would you ever find yourself
being like well you know
how do you find that listen i i believe
in doug which is we've talked about this
i believe in diffuse unified glue
i believe in diffuse unified glue if you
can defuse issues between you and adam
you and gerard
and then we unify we don't have glue but
don't get me wrong i'm a pretty
competitive guy like competition i like
sports
but i'm not a fan of manipulators at all
like listen i have i'm allergic to
manipulators
i'm allergic to bullies i'm allergic to
those that want to play games
that i don't know if you call it hate on
i'll call that out yeah that's that's
not so i'm not
i'm not i'm not for that at all but man
if if you're
winning and killing it in the game more
power to you like your whole thing is
salute let me let me put it to you this
way like even the other day
uh you know tai lopez you don't hear the
name tai lopez a lot lately but tai
lopez four or five years ago was here in
my garage you know everybody was hating
on the guy here this is that right
yeah uh today you know i saw his post
the other day the guy looks chiseled the
guy looks amazing he looks
fully happy what he's doing he's not
creating content anymore but you know
he's buying something
good i'm very excited for the guy what
he's doing
yesterday you know me last week you know
me park called me she says pat you won't
even believe what happened i said what's
that
i got a call from joe rogan i said i
said i see you everywhere she says i
want to be on rogan next week
i said you have no idea happy emma she's
i'm going to tell him that the fact that
all this stuff happened after my
interview with you on youtube because
she got like four million views and then
she went on jordan peterson everybody
right
i said that's fantastic that's great and
then she was on rogue and she posted it
and it's been all over the news that
this was one of rogan's best interviews
ever whatever he's been here and he's
going to be on a rogue
yeah yeah but he's been out you've been
on rogan yeah before i'll be on again
17th of august yeah so so you see what
rogan's doing roman's freaking killing
you can't do nothing by the way here's
even crazier thing chris come on andrew
cuomo
what did i say about them when the
brothers were going back and forth what
did i say when they were doing a show
together
oh you loved them initially you said
this is great this guy has their own
reality because what it made me think
about is all i think about when i saw
that exchange
is what thanksgiving was when these guys
were in their teenage years with their
mom and dad
all i thought about is the dad that's
all i thought about all i thought about
is what kind of a smack talking
competitive environment that family was
raised on that's all i think about i
don't go to any other area but
yeah if you're playing games you're
manipulating you're dividing i'm not a
fan of you number one
mario cuomo by the way was a was a stud
baseball player
and he actually got signed for more
money by the yankees than mickey mantle
he was
he was a bust but he actually got signed
for more money
great story that's his that was his
initiative
what do you think about oh okay i kind
of saw this one coming
help us out here that's been working out
man that's on you phil
i mean that's someone help us out here
but tell me this tell me to stop with
cuomo right now so you got you got a
couple things that's going on let's
transition into that okay
so on one end you're seeing the story
about how you know
11 uh women are coming out okay well
first of all zoopy do you know do you
know who andrew cuomo is
yeah yeah yeah the governor of new york
yes yes
so you hear stories about his stuff is
coming out you know 11 not his stuff is
coming out but his stories are coming
out with 11.
his stuff's coming out yeah it's
definitely but 11 women are you know so
then the other day the awkward moment
where the transition from chris cuomo to
don
lamont and don says brother
i love you you know chris today we're
going to talk about the governor of new
york
in a split second second which was
calculated quickly kind of awkward but
what should happen to andrew should
biden's tell him he should step down
should he step down dude he should step
down i just think it's amazing that
this is what people are grasping on to
rather than the fact that he put
basically human time bombs into nursing
homes
in new york bingo leading to thousands
upon thousands of unnecessary
deaths through his policies of putting
people who tested positive with kovit
back into nursing homes
somehow people like completely gloss
over this one and you know
out of the two out of the two sins
committed i think that uh that one is
the is the more serious one
yeah then you know it's not diminishing
you know how he's behaved towards women
etc i don't allegedly i don't know all
the details of that
but it amazes me that we're living in a
society where that one
is considered you know we can gloss over
that first thing and that's the one that
you know so you think he should step
down absolutely he should have stepped
down
i mean killed 50 000 people last year
when he was accepting what he got an
emmy award
we all know that's not gonna happen so
we all know
what i'm saying to you is all of that
what you're saying that's not going to
happen he's not going to step down
because of
the nursing home that's not going to
happen i'm talking about should he step
down for these
allegations not allegations
investigation that comes up i'll just
read it to you biden calls como to quit
after damning sexual harassment report
the guardian reports joe biden has led
the
calls from both parties for new york
governor andrew cuomo to resign
after an investigation new york attorney
general later james unveiled the results
of an investigation on tuesday show that
coma engagement unwanted groping kissing
and hugging
and made inappropriate comments to
multiple women i think he should resign
set the president
so it's not like uh you know you're
sitting canon asked about cuomo's
attempt to defend himself by using an
image in which he's
making physical contact with biden
himself the president said look i'm not
going to
fly spec this i'm sure there were some
impre embraces that were totally
innocent but apparently the attorney
general decided that there were things
going on so
he blamed his italian heritage i'm
italian we're a little handsome
come on man but but so on on this
on the premise on the story of 11 should
he resign based on that
i lean to a yes adam um
look there's a lot of people that are
asked to step down some people do
some people don't i mean
do i think he's gonna skip step down no
i also think you should do you think you
should okay so
they didn't what they're asking them to
step down for are these harassment
claims
hear you on that bro like the everything
you did with the nursing homes
i don't live in new york so i'm not
following all that much but
there is something called due process i
mean if these accusers
you know our not lying he does have
deserve his time in court i'm not a
cuomo guy or an anti-cuomo guy
you know i'm not i'm not should he
resign because of this because i don't
think he should resign i don't think he
will resign
but if the facts come out that he did do
this [ __ ] yeah no
the facts did come out there so that's
what they're saying not in a court of
law though
so if i if i'm in the president is
asking you to resign he's a democrat
it's not like a republican's calling out
a democrat
democratic political the president a
democrat
on a democrat to resign yes so this is
this is exactly a lot of a lot of the
news
that's like trump asking desantis to
resign and would desantis
resign no trump if trump asked to resign
if this santa's had something like this
the amount of pressures would be for him
to have to resign well you brought that
up
how many people when speaking of groping
asked trump to drop out of the race when
that billy bush
yeah you know i get what he say like
i think that's very different how's it
different i think that's very different
because
that would be like firstly that that
tape was from like the 90s right
that was not the it was from wave it was
from decades before he began
not decades maybe a few years billy bush
access
let's factor what was the date i don't
know i think it was at least a decade
before i'm going to check it out but
the point is i think it is over 10 years
yeah it was a it was that was a private
conversation
right like let's be real we're all guys
here we're not let's not it was
locker room talk two thousand yeah okay
so exactly ten years
yeah right that's a long time yeah that
but but that's a private conversation
the conversation
with caroline before this started was
wait let's be real men women people
people we've all had conversations in
private that you wouldn't want someone
that you wouldn't want to come out
to show to the public right he wasn't
president at the time
it was a private conversation basically
every conversation i had with gerard
yeah yeah exactly
right you wouldn't want that coming out
there people make jokes whatever
so you know and yeah so that's a
different thing to actually
like physically groping people and
was that done while that's done while
cuomo was governor right
yes am i correct yes yeah so so it's
totally different you're talking about a
physical act and you're talking about
that
you're talking about the fact that he
was asked yeah
i don't think i don't think cuomo should
resign because biden
said he should right i think what he
actually has done
if again allegedly if if if if he did it
and
he's got that guilty conscience and he's
like you know what like i screwed up
then yeah i think by the way is there a
worse word
allegedly he donates all his money to
charity it never it's always like
allegedly he's doing some grover here's
everything here's the question though
go ahead well next five moves right
we're not asking the right questions
frankly why
you talk you said it's rare for a
democrat to tell another democrat
it is and it isn't because what is never
going to happen in new york
what will never happen in new york state
right now tell us
will a republican ever be elected either
mayor of new york city or governor of
new york state
i think so let's not say never i think
so juliana was there i mean it's not
not in this environment and not right
now we're talking 20 25 years old
i think the best ideas always wins so if
the people are sick of the wokeness
trust me
just trust me on this they would they
wouldn't they would not
the jersey just trust me they would not
be doing this
if they thought there was any any chance
of them losing
the the gubernatorial bid all right so
they're going to take out
cuomo who has tried to sprint left with
his rhetoric but is actually a pretty
moderate dude
yeah and why because they want to push
further left the
the epicenter of the far left
progressive movement justice democrats
in particular
is brooklyn new york they have brooklyn
new york and they have la
and like like a cancerous cell they are
spreading from there
so right now you have yang and you have
aoc
aoc can moonwalk into the into the the
the mayor of new york she paul's
incredibly popular in new york and yang
is not polling well and they want yang
yang with paul well as the governor
so the progressive wing of the party can
get a two for one
this is what i told you was gonna happen
the the democrats are not worried about
republicans because republicans
have no fight in them and they've given
up on these areas they have no fight
whatsoever
they're not going after new york they're
solidifying the areas that they have
so now the democrats are cow towing to
the far left progressive wing of the
party
and the far left wing of the party is
going after cuomo so if cuomo is not
going to resign what cuomo needs to do
is push back and he needs to immediately
say hey joe biden that's an interesting
thing you think i should resign
what happened to that woman that you use
as a bowling ball that uh
that you ended up deciding you know that
that nobody needs to know about that
we're worried about trump
talking about grabbing a woman by the
kitty you were actually accused of doing
it
in the halls and she was your intern and
somehow someway
she disappeared on the campaign trail
somehow someway she went away why don't
you resign uncle joe
why don't you take corn pop and go down
to delaware and braid your leg hair
now i'm going to stay right here all
right until you you resign first
and then i got to define how
then you got cuomo needs to then
immediately turn
hard against the left side of the party
and that is how he can redefine himself
and we really want to do it
can we just we need to just defund all
of these politicians man
like slingshot i don't know again not
from new york
but who just allegedly won the allegedly
the mayor of new york city race it was a
black conservative
former who's winning mayor of new york
city that bill de blasio
but there's a new there's a new race
going on right now yeah but it's not
until next year
if he resigns who takes over if who
resigns if if
governor if cuomo rezans who takes over
uh would be his um uh
the assistant it's not the attorney
general they they have a weird
succession
they don't have an assistant can you
pull up who who takes over if cuomo
resigns can i just go google that real
quick who takes over
by the way is it ironic that the
governors of this would be his fourth
term by the way oh really they have no
is that ironic the governor of new york
and the governor
of california are both being asked to
respond
who's kathy hokel kathy h-o-c-h-u-l
she's the next in line in case he was to
resign now i'll tell you somebody you
should have her name
kathy hopkins see who that is chris
christie
should have resigned after bridgegate
and then that would have given him
a of new jersey wikipedia
the these eight years of horror phil
murphy is an american
ultimate knucklehead the bucktooth
goldman sachs boston assets she'll be
the first female governor to new york
states hogan
showed that the county clerk was one of
the 2007 congress she was assumed
her seat in congress previously she was
a deputy county clerk
interesting so she would take over if
cuomo was to resign by the way andrew
cuomo's team since you're watching this
we have reached out to you multiple
times for an interview request
multiple times if you could just respond
to us one time that would be fantastic
really appreciate you
and and what we reached out to them is a
special project that
will be announced here soon that may may
do pretty good uh i don't know if you uh
we can reveal any of it but may do
something special here when it's uh
when it's launched anyways okay so cuomo
you're saying yes you're saying no
you're saying he's not going to
you're saying he should and you're
saying he should your strategy actually
is pretty yeah that was a pretty
interesting what about the follow-up
story that he sounds like a needy
boyfriend like please come back to new
york please let me read that story as
well i just don't the two don't go
together
it's weird that people live in new york
city by choice but anyway yeah i don't
think
you're not a fan of new york city bro i
left i left you been you spent time in
new york it's yeah jersey and new york
are tattooed on my own i love new york
i love visiting new york city i'll say
is it yeah this is the best city i love
it visiting's one thing but
living there there's certain places
people live and i'm like man if you can
get out why are you still there you
lived in saudi arabia for 19 years
oh my god you'd rather live in saudi
arabia than new york
you guys don't have a clue no really
clue
really no well how's it going the fact
that you're the fact that you're
stepping
in saudi arabia you all don't have a
clue like how
the fact you're comparing i'm like dude
like shout out to my boy
mitchell by the way audio to new york
city bro
enlighten me because i'm like i'm
serious are you living in the please
please go visit were you living in a
place
for people who don't know wait let them
talk about it for people who don't know
tell us about saudi arabia what is it
like living there about
like living there like in like an expat
community bro
like you're talking zero crime rate
you're talking
zero taxes you're talking amazing
amenities
fantastic infrastructure incredible
communities fantastic schools
the company you work for paying for your
child's education
up to college level you're talking about
free healthcare
you're talking about fantastic weather
is this specifically in expat
communities you said
yeah so this part but a lot of what i'm
talking about is
the whole country saudi arabia has no
taxes period
okay um the infrastructure around the
seas even if you're talking riad jetta
etc
it's excellent very extraordinarily low
crime rates like you or
you are safer in any saudi city than you
are in any major city in the us
by miles not even not even comparable by
miles
um do you live under the same laws is
there
are they like were the women in your
family uh forced sharia law
which law are you talking about well my
understanding of saudi arabia is that
there
are repressive cultural laws about what
you can wear what you can say what you
can post
you know the there is no liquor there
right it's not
alcohol yeah alcohol i'm out i'm out bro
alcohol-free yeah if that's a thing
if that's a big thing for you women
specifically do they have to wear the
hajib
so the hijab you mean the job so it
depends so stuff has also all changed so
i left saudi in 2008.
so things have actually changed quite
significantly from what i understand
over the past decade because women can
drive now
everyone can drive now yes that's a big
deal that is because they couldn't drive
2016. well there was just a story
recently of women who snuck in to watch
a soccer game and i think we're stoned
to death though
so in saudi yeah
okay yeah please verify that one because
that sounds sketch
okay but there you gotta admit it sounds
awesome
see if we can pull that out women don't
have it easy in saudi arabia
look look you're not the type of you're
not the tourism bureau of saudi arabia
has never been there but i mean i'm
trying to understand yeah that's why i'm
laughing because i'm like when did you
go
right i lived there for 19 years so um
saudi arabia
basically grew up there i grew up in
saudi arabia dude i wasn't i went to
school there until i was
i would have stayed i mean i went to
boarding school from the age of 11
back in the uk so i was back and forth
between the two countries from 11 to 20.
um but you know and like where i grew up
it's why i don't sound british
right because a lot of people i grew up
with were american i grew up in an
extraordinarily diverse community people
from all over the world most my teachers
were american i was in the american
school system
from preschool up until fifth grade in
fact interesting um and then i switched
over to the british
so saudi is a man on every level it's a
gigantically
misunderstood country in a lot of ways
so obviously as an expat
you have a certain experience which is
if you have you been in dubai
i have not yes okay you've been in dubai
so
closer closer to that than like some
it's not
saudi arabia is not iran just so you
know it's not uh
and by the way keep this in mind what
he's saying are you
saudi arabia yeah yeah it's not even
close yeah people can people conflate
them
yeah but but kai can you pull out what i
just sent you 10 questions about expat
life in saudi arabia answer this one
website
okay interesting and uh one of one of
the things that if you can pull that up
kai yeah
uh it's actually pretty interesting uh
what it talks about how women
flirt with men like dating life in saudi
arabia go all the way down so one thing
for gerard it was in iran
it was in iran okay yeah okay keep going
down conflate them okay accept
press collect accept okay keep going
down what's that going to keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going family
values okay keep going
keep going a little lower it's about to
come up here
lower a little lower right there they
didn't get a kid first states must be
low key affairs if you live in the same
compound or can let them into yours
you will likely spend your first date at
the movies or the compounds restaurant
and most likely society rules don't
apply within a compound this is great
relaxed option for a couple some
restaurants and big cities also offer
private cabins and are
lacks about letting genders mix within
their establishment asking around your
expat circles is a good way to discover
date spots okay so extremely
conservative many
dating a local many young saudis now
flirt more openly on apps such as
facebook tinder snapchat and
and who share however women in
particular may still shy away from
sending photos over messaging apps for
fear of family or percussion snapchat is
popular
and as a woman you may well be asked
uh a moment in snapchat literally
snapchat possible you may also be
so dating is it the goal of the lord kai
go little lord to see what else can
saudis marry foreigners over seven
hundred thousand saudi women
ten percent of all married saudi women
are also americans our foreign doesn't
know
no corresponding figures are available
for saudi men married to non-national
so if it's a saudi spouse you're looking
for there is hope
arranged marriages marriages are still
often arranged between conservative
families
lgbt relations homosexuality transgender
individuals moving to saudi arabia
should be aware that it is illegal for
men
to act and dress like women and vice
versa homosexuality activity is also
against the law
and attracts the death penalty whoa
that said no booze women may
find it easier to meet and socialize
with potential partners but they say
what it's like to work inside so only
muslims can
marry in saudi arabia therefore expat
couples of other faiths need to wait
outside
are you are you are you muslim no i'm
christian christian okay
yeah so are they why did you deliver why
did you leave
uh you retire at 60 there so my dad
reached 60
and the company he worked for you retire
at 60 and so
by the way if you do the math if you do
the math so this whole thing about well
you why can't why don't they need taxes
why don't they tax anybody oil money
okay they got the national it's like
dubai doesn't tax you right and
unemployment is nothing
but save data and tax tax corporations
that money goes to the corporations
what's the big deal if corporations pay
for kids college education nothing we
can afford it
what's the big deal if corporations pay
for your health insurance nothing they
can afford it
what's the big deal you know what
companies can do if they didn't pay
taxes
saudi aramco
yeah so that's uh so so so i'll explain
so with the expat thing so saudi aramco
so when i grew up there this is you know
in the
you know from the 80s to the 90s early
thousands uh
so a company like saudi aramco they
basically have their own towns
so everyone where i lived worked for the
same company and they have like
four or five of those like dotted around
so um they're called camps which i think
was was mentioned that's a throwback to
the industrial revolution yeah
so so it's weird i mean even me being in
the uk i mean it was weird when i went
to houston and even parts of
miami etc it's weird because it looks
like
this place looks more like saudi than it
looks like england
right so when i was in houston i was
like whoa it looks like saudi because of
the refineries and all that or because
the company
just everything the way everything is
laid out yeah it's beautiful if you pull
up saudi
arabia and put up pictures the buildings
the the structures are beautiful
how old were you when you left uh saudi
20 20 did you have a girlfriend
uh in the uk yeah but in
saudi did you have a girlfriend there
not in saudi no not inside so i went to
boarding school from 11.
so i was in boarding school and then in
university from 11 to 20 in the uk
so the first time you had a girlfriend
how old were you 15
15. yeah but that was in saudi uh no
this was in england
in boarding school in boarding school in
england yeah how much time
so you were literally going back back
and forth between the two countries you
were going to boarding school yeah so
so during terms so during term time i'm
in england
and then during the vacations i'm back
how many months here are you in saudi
uh during that period yeah uh how much
how much vacation time is there i know
four or five months four or five months
a year you're in saudi the rest of the
time you're in boarding school and you
can
yeah what is that i believe it's called
hogwarts
he's a he's an oil they did they do film
harry potter and partially in my
university of course is that right yeah
in oxford no way yeah
um i think what is it uh christchurch
college i think
you went to oxford yeah how was oxford
how was oxford oxford was cool man it
was cool
is it what is it the harvard of you know
is it
is the best yeah sell us on oxford sell
us an oxford well it's
the oldest university in the world um i
i hate uh first i absolutely hate ivy
league elites though but please go on
that's all right i like you up till now
it's not ivy league it's not ivy league
that's not a thing in the uk um yeah i
mean oxford and cambridge are
you know for decades have been the best
if not centuries
been two of the best universities in the
entire world certainly the top two in
the uk
um i studied computer science which was
i didn't love my subject i didn't love
my subject but oxford itself is a city
have you ever been to oxford no the city
is beautiful
absolutely beautiful city the
architecture is
mind-blowing incredible how far is it
from london is it is it only an hour and
a half oh okay
yeah about 90 miles or something like
that um so is it a party town with
students because the school is there
there's two universities so there's
oxford
and then there's oxford brooks um so
there it's it's quite a student oriented
place
it's quite a student-oriented place but
it's it's oxford's a fantastic city it's
one of my
probably top five cities in the uk and
i've been to all of them
um but yeah it's a great place obviously
you know hyper academic
incredibly you're surrounded by
incredibly smart people all the time
which means you're always having
great conversations and it's it's good
you know when you're surrounded by
people who inspire you in some way shape
or form there's a lot of
value in that and when you're somewhere
with so much history and literally i
mean i think my college in oxford was
built in the 1200s um didn't c.s lewis
go to oxford was c.s lewis he went to
oxford he taught at oxford i'm not sure
yeah i'm not certain there's a there's a
movie about c.s lewis his story is
and i think he used to go can you pull
up c.s lewis profile
is that the rhodes scholars is that
oxford uh yeah yeah oxford has
rhodes scholars so you get it so oxford
is more like a boston
yeah he went to oxford cambridge yeah
he had academics yeah he's still i don't
have you seen his movie put cs lewis
movie
you ever seen this movie i haven't oh my
gosh i highly recommend anybody i can
watch it it's not a
story of a not or not those movies the
story uh
a life story movie yeah type that
there's a movie that you know who plays
it
uh anthony hopkins plays it there you go
shadowlands
if you've never seen this movie it is
absolutely fascinating how interesting
of a human being this guy was
from going and being an atheist to
writing mere christianity to divorce
letters i think he wrote divorce letter
screw tape letters
uh uh you know maybe one of the greatest
authors of all time on the stuff that he
wrote and
he would go to oxford and they would
debate to hear those debates that he
would have with all these other
scholars and professors and educators
you know the the part about
was it a big debate type of school were
you guys always was it a debate format
is that how you guys learned
uh no not like for typical not for
typical learning but there's the oxford
union which you may have heard of where
they they bring in speakers and
they have uh you know there's debate
societies and stuff like that
um were you ever a part of it or no
because no i was never personally a part
of it i wasn't personally a part of it i
was kind of
i can see you doing good at that like
yeah sincerely i can see you actually
doing good at that that's how you debate
yeah did uh did your philosophy did your
did your kind of libertarian philosophy
originate there in oxford has that come
later in life because
i'm wondering here between the saudi
upbringing it could be my
my misunderstanding of saudi culture
sure and in oxford it would it would
seem that
that your uh your belief system
although at least as it's presented
through social media seems to kind of be
uh in it
it doesn't converge with with what your
upbringing should be right
is that you seem to have come from a
very controlled environment and now
you seem to promote a lot of personal
freedom i didn't come from a
soup i didn't come from a super
controlled environment not in my
household nor
in you know so so saudi's interesting
because you know
here's something that's interesting to
know is that you know what people call
like the left-right political spectrum
doesn't apply globally well it doesn't
even apply anymore it's like yeah but
18th century french yeah but
you know if you talk to people in most
of europe or in right in us you know
it's always the left and the right and
you know
democrats republicans we were talking
about this earlier right so
so like i said somewhere like saudi it's
ultra conservative on certain things
sort of in the middle on certain things
and actually sort of you know
very it's a combination of all first of
all
it's a monarchy right so there there are
no kingdoms
what's the liberal part of saudi arabia
this is what i mean right there's no
there's no wings like there's no not
even wings so what are they liberal on
okay so what i mean is so okay look at
the things some people in the u.s
what do you what do u.s progressives
want they want free health care saudi
has that they want free schooling saudi
has that
they even want some of them the extreme
the far lefties want free university
somebody has that okay right what do
libertarians want libertarians want no
taxes because taxation is theft
saudi has that right why are you why are
you living in uk why don't you go live
there
um i don't really i've as far as i'm
concerned i've left the uk
oh wait so you're now what you're i
don't know i'm a global international
i'm a believer i'm a global nomad after
the past year and a half i was like you
know what i'm done
are you a globalist i'm not a
globalization
you're living anywhere and everywhere i
don't know i'm in the u.s for the next
three months
um beyond that we we shall see i mean
i feel that i'm such a this is what you
and i always have our heated discussions
about dude you don't know what it's like
to have
corrupt politicians steal your home from
you they steal your home
and then you have to then adjust because
if you don't adjust then you're going to
become a criminal
and that's you know so they they've
literally
i'm sure you didn't want to leave your
home but they've made it an untenable
situation man
the uk is a yeah it's i feel sad like i
was i was going to end up leaving the uk
anyway because
my audience in the u.s is much bigger
you know more opportunities here etc so
you know i could well end up living in
florida texas etc once i get my visa
um but you know as for me right now
unfortunately i'm location independent
with my business and everything i do so
i don't i'm not tied to any particular
city
or country um which is wonderful
so you know as far as i'm concerned i'm
kind of flexible right now but
i'm very disillusioned with the uk now
which makes me sad because i do love the
country
are you leaning towards anywhere are you
leaning towards where you want to live
or
not if it's in the u.s probably florida
texas or tennessee
outside the u.s um you know i'm a big
fan of central and eastern europe i like
czech republic hungary poland romania
places like that
um thoughts on norway by the way
thoughts on norway
i've never been there oh so you gotta go
i haven't been to norway myself
singapore singapore i don't know i've
i've heard that singapore has been
terrible throughout all this um
singapore is another weird one because
it's
very authoritarian um but it's also very
free market
yeah it's it's it's weird you know it's
another one i think sort of
like interview that lived in singapore
uh the the crypto billionaire that
bought
peoples every day is for six and a half
minutes yeah
yeah and he swears by singapore he
swears by what it's like to live in
singapore yeah singapore
so what do you consider home at this
point
um yeah yeah i mean look in terms of
where i'm from is always a weird
question because i'm literally a british
nigerian who grew up in saudi arabia and
went to an american school and does not
have a british accent yeah sounds like
america
yeah exactly and has quite a lot of you
know
american values like i always get told
man to be more american than
most americans right um and
my you know i'm i don't like any
political party but i'm more of a
republican than i am a
tory right in terms of my actual views
on stuff
and that's pretty rare in the uk and i
think that's for me not growing up there
living in saudi arabia so
with me you know i mean like there's
there's pro one thing i've really
learned you know i've traveled to
about 36 countries and had heavy
exposure to all these different cultures
we've mentioned
and with me one thing i've really
learned is you know there's pros and
cons to
all different cultures and political
systems and ways of doing things it's
not just
one thing i think a lot in the west is
people kind of have this okay this is
the one way
of doing things this is how we do it and
everything we do is the best way of
doing it
and i'm like no some things are right
there's lots of stuff movie america's
yeah well people say that but then they
haven't often been anywhere else right
but daniel tasha the thing is like
people hate us because we keep saying
we're number one the terrorists don't
like it just
just say we're top ten top ten yeah yeah
they're top ten all right that's fine
pb question for you you you kind of have
a similar
story i mean you've been all over the
world you've traveled what do you
consider a home
oh listen it's born in iran made in
america oh i've heard that
born in iran made in america it's that
simple for me i've been all over the
world
when you're in the military you go
everywhere when you're you know
iran you're coming up you live at a
refugee camp germany you see it
traveled to i don't know 50 countries
you know with
all the traveling we've done but nothing
comes close to this
nothing comes you just think america is
your home if the ideas stay the same
nothing comes close to this if the ideas
don't stay the same
listen there's going to be a lot of
competition going on out there where
people can
take market share away from america
today if i was running another country
i would look at it right now and i would
be targeting
uh creators innovators those who want to
be left alone i would be targeting them
like you wouldn't even believe because
in america what they could do is
uh a state like california you know they
can turn texas into california you know
how they say don't
california my florida don't california
leave your politics yeah
but but if you're in a different country
i can't just send 50 000 people on
greyhound to your place
unless that country is american unless
if that country is america but if i'm
living in it
if i'm if i'm in another country right
now and i'm the president or prime
minister you got a lot of opportunity
today you got a lot of
i would be thinking about getting those
because today you can run a business
from anywhere if you've got if you've
got an internet you got zoom you can run
it from anywhere i'd be recruiting
people like him
i'd be recruiting innovators like you
would not believe
nonstop today so uh but yeah guys like
that are out there i mean a lot of
people right now
are similar to where zooby's at where
he's trying to think about where to live
where not to live
he's like a hot free agent one of my
friends one of my friends in quebec
yesterday just
sold all sold all of his stuff and he's
just like i'm done with canada
you know and and it said he's connect
you know he's from there probably people
quebec specifically is insane right now
there were people that weren't allowed
in their backyards
and their neighbors were calling the
mounties on them for going in their
backyards
like australia they got the army out now
yeah
and for stay at home let's go into some
of these other stores that we got here
let's talk about journalists so record
number of journalists jailed worldwide
this is committed to protect
journalists its annual global survey the
committee to protect journalists found
at least 274
journalists in jail in relation to their
work on december 1st 2020
exceeding the high of 272 in 2016 china
which arrested several journalists for
their coverage on the pandemic was the
world's worst
jailer for second year in a row it was
followed by turkey
which continued to try journalists free
on parole
and arrest new ones egypt which went to
great length
you said egypt by the way yesterday to
keep custody of journalists
not convicted of any crime and then
saudi arabia which the
the story doesn't kind of help your
story zooby but there you go
saudi arab journalists okay countries
where the number of jail journalists
rose significantly
include belarus where mass protests have
been short over the
disputed re-election of the long-time
president and ethiopia where political
unrest has degenerated into armed
conflict within the united states
no journalists were jailed at the time
of cpj
prison census exactly i can name two
yeah
julian assange edward snowden
immediately but
an unprecedented 110 journalists were
arrested or criminally charged in 2020
around 300 were assaulted the majority
by law enforcement
according to the u.s press freedom
tracker so
journalists is it a good time to be a
journalist or is it a bad time to be a
journalist or is it just
where you live dude one we need
journalists we don't have
journalists anymore we have political
operatives that write for periodicals we
need actual people that are fact finders
that are that are intellectually curious
that are uh politically
agnostic or at least professional enough
to keep their
their bias uh to their side and be
objective in their reporting
one of the biggest problems that we have
right now in the country and i imagine
in the world
is we cannot operate on the same reality
depending on
where you're getting your information
you have a completely different
understanding
of the reality that we are living in and
it goes back to what you were talking
about the left versus the right
i ascribe to something called the
horseshoe theory i don't know if you
could pull it out yeah horseshoe theory
okay
it's it's not left and right it's the
north and the south on the spectrum that
matter more the libertarian or the
authoritarian
if you're conservative of your ideas
that's fine as long as there's no
authoritarianism behind it you don't
force me into your conservative ideas
sharia law
whatever fascism all right if you're to
the left and you believe in
equality equity and egalitarian society
okay great
present it and if it's a good idea
people will follow it if you force
people into it if you seize their
property communism okay
so the further left and right you go the
closer those ideologies are
okay the further left the further to the
left you get away from the center the
further to the right you get away from
the center
the closer they are communists and nazis
are much closer to each other
than people in the center of the
spectrum people either to the right of
center
to the left or center have more in
common okay so that's what i ascribe to
and what we have now is we have people
who are making it they're justifying bad
behavior if anybody's ever read
uh alexander schulze nietzsche the the
gulag archipelago
it's it's the most important you talk
about a hero that book
literally changed my life it's a very
dense book that book changed my life
because he talks about how quickly it
changes
and as soon as good men don't act evil
wins every single day
and all that happens is it's well that
journalist was well
that journalist was a bad guy well he
deserves it or or well you know he
shouldn't have written that he knows
what the rules
why why what is so wrong with this guy
writing something that you don't want
the world to hear
let the world hear it and let the let
the ideas play out you're repressing
these people
it doesn't matter what your ideology is
it could have been christianity in the
1600s
it could have been uh imperialism it
could have been communism whatever it is
as soon as you become
authoritarian in the nature you are in
the wrong it doesn't matter left or
right
the problem is the problem is that well
firstly some people would disagree with
that last sentence which is part of the
problem right because some people are
very authoritarian we've really seen
that come to light
in the past year and a half they really
do they love authority yeah
and the another big problem is that a
lot of people just don't
actually have solid principles right and
having principles means sometimes you
have to
defend people and ideas you don't like
or at least the ability for them to be
presented out there and be presented
right so you know i think
i think aoc has terrible ideas i think
like you know i i i think a lot of ideas
are terrible
but i would never want you know someone
to be censored so
like look at look okay look at the
response to come gosh i mean
i think people still downplay how
significant this is i mean your sitting
president
got de-platformed from all of social
media back in january it's insane
insane right and people what's how do
people justify i don't like i don't like
trump
right people let their emotions and
their feelings because they're not
principled
right a principled person even if you
despise trump you can be like i despise
trump i think he's this i think he's
that
but he should be not not just because
he's the president but
you know we're a free country he should
be allowed to express his
ideas he didn't break the law he didn't
right so um
you know there there's that but because
people allow like their personal
biases and their feelings towards things
to determine
who should be allowed to speak or what
degree or whatever that that's
always a problem because then you know
people have different ideas and
ideologies and belief systems
and as soon as you try to like you said
when you try to force that on other
people
that becomes the issue it's the same you
know people understand it i think quite
well with religion
okay so you know i'm a christian some
people are muslim some people are
atheists jewish et cetera there's lots
and lots of different religions and
belief systems
and you know you can espouse your belief
you can believe what you want etc
if i you know get on a horse and holding
a bible in one hand and a sword in the
other and i start want to go on some
crusade to start you know converting
non-believers
i think people be no you can't do that
right if i want to strap myself with a
suicide vest and start blowing people up
crashing planes into buildings whatever
supposedly to spread that that's that's
the problem right that's that's the line
so
you can be you can believe what you want
but if you're trying to force other
people to believe what you believe based
on force
that's the problem it doesn't matter if
it's political if it's religious
whatever about a year ago when this
whole thing's taken place year and a
half ago i went up and i said
okay how are parents judged parents are
judged based on what
providing what a roof over your head you
know feeding you
taking care of you but you're also based
on the behavior of your children right
behavior your children how your kids
react in school okay great how is a
how is a coach for a basketball team or
football team judge whether they win or
lose whether you win or lose
you know playoffs performance getting
better all of that okay
how is a coach of a college football
team judge how you
the parents wanting you to wanting to
recruit all that stuff right
how was a president judge how is the ceo
of a company judge how is the sales
person judged
every one of us is judged this podcast
is judged based on what
if we lose viewers what they're saying
is we don't like your topic
i'm going to another one screw you great
we're judge nonstop as you run a podcast
valuetainment is judge if we don't do
well we don't grow if the topic is not
good
you do a podcast if you don't give
viewers they didn't like it you did
great deal
you do video gets four million views on
twitter guess what the audience saying
hey zooby do more of these things we
want to hear from you right
we're constantly judged however how are
journalists judge so i found this
article
and this article is society of
professional journalists
okay how they're judged is based on four
things
seek truth and report it go to the next
one
minimize harm okay act independently
be accountable and transparent that is
the code
of journalism go up let me read a few of
them go all the way up go all the way up
kai
and let me read some of these things
here so let's look at the first one here
seek truth and report on a journalist
should
take responsibility for the accuracy of
their work very verify information
before releasing it
okay that would have already eliminated
80 percent of dossier stories
we have an insider that's telling us on
what is the word they use
unknown names unnamed sources that told
us adam schiff i've got this
original sources whenever possible
remember that neither speed
nor format excuses inaccuracy twitter
provide context take special care not to
misrepresent or oversimplify
promoting previewing or summarizing the
story the headlines gather
update and correct information
throughout the life of a new story
gather update and correct right be
cautious when making promises but
keep the promises they make so far so
far is anybody doing the left right or
middle is anybody doing this
right now every single valuetainer needs
to take this let me let me continue
we're gonna put the link for everybody
see this year
okay so next identify source clearly the
public is
entitled to as much information as
possible to judge the reliability and
motivations of sources
next consider sources motives before
promising
anonymity reserve anonymity for reason
for sources who may face danger
retribution or other harm
fine diligently seek subjects of news
coverage to allow them to correspond to
criticism or allegations of wrongdoing
avoid undercover or other surreptitious
methods of gathering information unless
traditional open methods will not yield
information value to the program and you
see how this is going right okay go to
the next one let me read the next one
here
avoid stereotyping go a little bit
higher avoid stereotyping
journalists should examine the ways
their value experiences may shift
never plagiarize always attribute okay
so that's that part minimize harm
no no go up go up this is the most
important one label
advocacy and commentary
[Music]
label advocacy and commentary what does
that mean to you that means
stop presenting your opinion as fast
facts okay
minimize harm balance the public's need
for information against potential harm
or discomfort pursuit
of the news is not a license for
arrogance or undue
intrusiveness so 80 of them are fired
okay eric 80
of them are fired okay show compassion
for those who may be affected by news
coverage okay
use high sensitivity when dealing with
juveniles victims of sex crimes and
sorts of subjects who are inexperienced
or unable to give consent
fine recognize that legal access to
information differs
from an ethical justification to publish
or publish a broadcast
avoid pandering to lurid curiosity even
if others do it
you realize none of this stuff this is
what they're held accountable to how
they're judged
i immediately go to the kid wearing the
maga hat who got painted as
destroyed yeah and they they suit him
keep going up
act independently kai go up act
independent avoid conflicts of interest
real or perceive disclose unavoidable
refuse gifts favors fees free travel and
special treatment
be wary of sources offering information
for favors or money
deny favorite treatment to advertisers
okay that definitely does
well that goes into your next story
about the ccp yeah let me continue
here on the last one then we'll go into
that story explain ethical choices and
process for to audiences
respond quickly to questions about
accuracy clarity or
unfairness acknowledge mistakes and
correct them promptly expose
unethical conduct in journalism
including within their organization
abide by the same high standards they
expect of others
by the way that's journalism okay from
1926.
that's changed in 95 years later that's
changed in 95 years so
when you go and talk about journalists
maybe some of this stuff
by the way on some of the countries
you're talking about like china you know
turkey you know saudi arabia or some of
the countries that they're talking about
look that's silencing is what they're
trying to do when you go and talk about
the government you cannot do that in
america
you get a raise if you do that right if
you're calling out the government
however
that's journalism now let's go to the
next one here story
chinese mouthpiece paid in the u.s
newspaper 19 million dollars in ads
printing report this is page five if you
want to go
to it i haven't been very quiet lately
but uh we're gonna be okay i just want
you to know don't stress out too much so
this is i'm learning
can i just say one thing yeah there's
certain subjects
where you know people can't wait to
speak
this is one of those subjects where
you've got two ears and one mouth for a
reason and i'm actually learning you had
some
amazing points you had some amazing
points you just went through all this
and i'm learning here this is something
that i think the entire audience is
learning right now because
i mean this is the one thing we always
talk about there's no like who
who's one journalist that we can point
at and say wow that's the guy back in
the day was walter cronkite who is today
i don't know maybe he's a joe rogerson
um maybe it's joe rogers
um what do you think my bread bear
uh great bench press that's it
i like bread bear i like bread bear i
don't know that uh i'm a huge fan of
zakaria we know that and i'll say one
thing about fried zakaria he's on cnn so
everyone you know in the chatterbox
he's amazing journalist he's indian born
american made
i'm sure you can respect that he did
something the other day on his show that
i was like whoa he did his show and he
goes hey my last point i actually said
something
last week that was wrong and i'm here to
correct it today and this was the point
it wasn't even a major point
but he came out and i was like oh okay
thanks but i think
more journalists need to do that brian
stelter no
do you know what you know a big problem
is that the word uh when when people
think
so journalists and pundits are different
things yep but they
they've been merged you know don lemon
is a pundit
tucker carlson is a pundit right uh sean
hannity
yeah they're they're pundits rachel
maddow are pundits but
they're conflated with journalists yeah
right to me a journalist is someone who
who
gives the news like reads the news and
it's actually a fairly
unbiased yeah as long as what they're
reading is objective
there's not much room to you know they
don't even really get space to give
their opinion maybe they could do it in
their tone or whatever
so but i think that when people think
journalists we go to these famous faces
who really are pundits more yeah they're
sort of journalists to a degree
well none of those guys would have
matched those scores by the way every
now and then
but they're not trying to but why can't
they put on the bottom of the screen
this is an opinion well they they use a
new show why can't
they kind of do so they put they don't
present it as
news they present it as editorial so
what do you mean presented it doesn't
say that on the tv
turn on your tv and it's boom the news
guy news lady all right i'm watching the
news espn
came out a year and a half ago and says
that we're no longer committed to sports
we're committed to editorializing sports
steven they they're not biggest
editorials
they don't they don't play highlights
anymore it's there's nothing light
there's no
i haven't i haven't watched mtv or espn
in it's got to be
i've watched honestly and this is all i
ever watched growing up was mtv
espn mtv espn just go back and forth
between those two things
hours and hours and hours every day i'd
go from singled out to sportscenter
to uh uh whatever trl trl live
to to uh you know then you know outside
the lines with
you know like i would just go back and
forth those two channels that was it
i i've watched maybe 15 minutes total of
the two channels
in the last two three years and it's
because they're no longer commit they
are the story and their narrative is
first
it's no longer about watching the home
runs of the dunks it's about
well what does this dunk mean for
society yeah and it's
like i don't care i don't care what you
have to say i don't
this is i think it's worth saying this
is this problem exists in the uk
but it's worse in the us it's really
really polarized here like the the media
it's very much
have you fully recognized that since
being here for the last month or so
i mean i've seen it for you many years
you know um i mean
i remember you know as a kid growing up
in saudi i mean we did get cnn out there
and fox news etc and i remember growing
up
everyone always knew that fox news was
like right leaning
but cnn was certainly deemed supposed to
be the center yeah yeah and it did it
did used to be
something in the new york times yeah it
was the paper of record yeah it did used
to be much more so whereas now
especially i i haven't i haven't owned a
tv for 12 years
so when i do watch the news it really
strikes me
how propagandistic it is right so i turn
it on and i'm just like whoa like this
is just straight down this side
especially when
trump was in office oh my gosh it was
literally like straight down this way
straight
what was his famous line about the media
the media the enemy of the man
you think the media took that well that
was a bar
who cares was he wrong he was right he
was right i mean the way they're
dividing people in the past year and a
half depends on what team
past year and a half you know half the
population thinks that you know
there's like a mild flu slash cold
that's going
around the world which is like you know
like very minimal other people
think that we're we're in the middle of
a
black plague armageddon and you know a
state like florida oh my gosh
you know what are they calling your
governor death santis like oh my gosh
florida's like
they're going to kill all the people
what it i mean i'm here i'm like those
are all the good people by the way we're
the bad people those are the things but
people are
really living and people are living in
absolutely different realities and that
creates and that was created by the
media
all around the world right intentionally
yeah intentionally which is where when
i'm like man the immediate is the enemy
of the people especially when
people are now fighting each other and
you know
literally people are advocating for
segregation now well that's my question
in the uk
the the uh are the politics i
identity politics as well there are
there their political divisions based on
your
immutable characteristics they've
imported it somewhat from the u.s
so the uk has a bad habit of taking the
the us's worst
the worst aspects of the us like i love
the usa one of my favorite countries in
the world
but there are a couple things here which
i think are really really toxic
socio-politically and culturally and one
of those things is
identity politics in its various forms
like in the us people are too obsessed
with race
way too obsessed with race i understand
it somewhat from the history i mean you
guys
use the terms asian american black
american african-american why am i
in england we say british british like
if someone said i'm black british or
after african british they'd be like why
why'd you say that like why using that
term right
but here like race is like big on
labeling yeah
the labeling it's it runs through
everything it runs through the meat and
people don't realize it because it's
like the default here
right but when you're looking at it as
an outsider i'm like why
why are you why is there always so in
the white
i don't think it always was the default
i think it points specifically to
carter and affirmative action because
be your when carter did affirmative
action this is just before pat
came here right so it became beneficial
to label yourself there became there
there became an actual profit incentive
i mean i think it'd be labeled i think
it goes way back
it goes way before that i mean the u.s
has a specific history in regards to
race right
and so these designations
yeah but you but you but uk didn't have
like you know slavery etc and
segregation the way jim crow all that
you didn't have all that and also the us
is much more
racially and ethnically diverse and so i
understand
where it comes from it's just that i'm
like yo it's 20 21
like why are people still really locked
into that
i don't think it's gonna go away it's a
formula to divide and it's working very
effectively but you know even
you talk about cnn earlier somebody
commented about ted turner if you've
ever read ted turner's book
call me ted i don't know if you guys
have read it or not the ending of the
book
is fascinating where he's interviewing
one of the
current uh folks at cnn and he says i'm
so disappointed what you guys have done
to cnn
this is not why i started cnn ted turner
ted turner said that since i didn't
start cnn to be like this
when did he say when did he say that
this this is a book he wrote years ago
this is not a recent book call me
i highly recommend everybody go by his
book call me ted it is
fascinating what this man did with his
life and how he went from who he was to
who he married to the personal life do
you know alcohol he talks openly about
everything
there is nothing he holds back he tells
himself i'm a great father i'm a
terrible husband like the stuff he goes
through with the book
it's a book you won't be able to put
down but at the end he calls out cnn
says i am so disappointed
with what cnn turned into at the end of
the book i highly recommend people
seeing it anyways let me go into the
story here
with what happened chinese chinese
mouthpiece paid the u.s newspapers 90
million dollars in ads
printing report this is a business
standard story one of china's main
propaganda outlets china daily
an english language newspaper controlled
by the chinese communist party has paid
more than 4.6 million dollars to the
washington post six million dollars to
wall street journal since 2016.
the u.s justice department documents
show let me say this one more time
4.6 million to washington post
6 million to wall street journal as per
the justice department reports china
daily also paid for advertisers and
several
other newspapers including new york
times foreign policy des moines register
cq roll call it spent a total of 11
million dollars on advertising in
newspapers and another 265 on
advertising with twitter the la times
seattle times atlanta journal
constitution the chicago tribune the
houston chronicle
the boston globe are all listed as
clients of china daily the china outlet
paid la times 650 000 for printing
services so question all of the stuff we
just talked about right all of this
stuff we just talked about
they're taking money from a company
that's controlled let me say this one
more time
china daily is an english language
newspaper controlled by the chinese
communist party so
i got a story with this adam you would
remember this kai you'll definitely
remember this we're doing an event
i don't know where this event was it may
have been sls i think it was sls
so while i'm doing event i get an email
from this uh major public
public uh pr firm in new york we want to
have a call with you so we go and have a
call with them
in uh uh new york uh we're a pr
firm but a hundred percent of the
clients they represent is from china
circuit
so i go look them up i'm like wow it's a
pretty big pr firm but it's all
china-based companies so i said there's
this non-profit organization in china i
have this an email kai do you remember
this
non-profit organization in china wants
to give me 600 000
of which i keep 300 000 of it the other
three hundred thousand dollars
at an event charity event in china i
give
the three hundred thousand dollars and i
donate it to that nonprofit organization
donated that i donate so let me say this
one more time 600k
i keep the 300 the other 300 i don't it
so we do a zoom with them we do a call
with them the most awkward call
and the way the man spoke was very
strange like
yeah yeah yeah you just come we fly you
we take care of you we come over here
and then we know we like what the work
you do we just want to give you six
hundred thousand dollars and you make a
big check and you give us three hundred
thousand dollars to our charity
but you can keep the other three hundred
thousand dollars and it's going to be a
great experience if you come out here
and do this i'm like huh
interesting i call my attorney he says
first of all you take this money
if it even shows it's like a speaking
gig it says if you even take this money
if you ever have any plans of doing
anything later on they're always going
to say
you know owned by china right but you
have to give them
credit on how brilliant they are yes
because they're willing to
buy influence and how many people would
say yes to that 600 000 auto check
a lot of people that's a lot of money
you keep 300 000 over you come out here
you do this but
so then the question becomes what is
wrong with a company taking money from a
china daily that's owned by a chinese
communist party is there anything
wrong with that that's number one number
two if there is something wrong with
that
why are they saying yes to it is it just
because about about profits
this is what's wrong with it what's
wrong with it is that they
presented their advertising as if it
were
native articles it's not just that they
took the advertising
advertising's fine all right newsmax
wants to do my pillow
my pillow guy wants to you know throw up
uh you know
q and stuff go for whatever fine but
don't present it as news
which is what the new york times of
washington post and everybody else did
they took the money
and then they took these articles that
were very clearly written
by chinese propagandists and they
presented them as if they were news
that's what was wrong in addition that's
the money we know about
what i'm more concerned about than these
these bought and paid for
corrupt uh news media organizations are
the universities
the universities have been taking so
much money
from china for so long and funneling
communist propaganda actual literal
communist propaganda
into the youth and it's working and it's
working they are buying
the future they set up confucian schools
that a lot of these
we are losing a war
most people are unaware is going on i
quoted that i literally said that
yesterday to someone
that's yeah that is that's the problem
and
and unless people recognize it and
develop a strategy to counteract it
dude hollywood and the entertainment
industry and the sports industry
like this this nba remember that john
cena thing where he came out yeah i
apologize
i'm so sorry started crying what are
your thoughts on yeah but but
there's was podcast i called seeing a
china's [ __ ]
by the way there are certain things that
we should be on the same page
there are certain things we should be on
the same page with this being one of
them
it's a common enemy they don't care
about america they don't care about the
democratic party they don't care about
the republican party
but the people that they like
are those who are for sale look at
presidents who couldn't be bought
look at presidents who could care less
whether you were gonna buy him with
money or not name presidents
historically that couldn't be controlled
by money
name presidents that come okay trump's
one of them who else jfk jfk is another
one who else oh teddy roosevelt dwight
eyes
not many in the last okay reagan wait a
minute reagan had money who else
okay abraham lincoln do you think
lincoln cared about money no what
happened to those four
you go go go go lincoln what happened to
him
literal or character assassination yeah
what happened to john f kennedy
what happened to reagan six inches away
yeah what happened to trump
they couldn't if they did what they did
to jfk with uh
with uh trump trump would have been
martyr trump would have gone down as the
greatest you know it would have been the
republican
you know he would have replaced reagan
if that would have happened are you
shocked that there wasn't
at least an attempt on trump i got to be
honest i was shocked i
uh how do we know there weren't yeah i i
uh i think to me i think to me
what's worse though what's worse though
what's worse though there are many
methods of assassination what's worse
character this color
this color revolution nothing worse than
character assassination i mean you saw
the article that came up with vanity
fair
how rudy giuliani went from a 911
hollowed mayor
to 2021 haunted ghoul if you read that
story about rudy giuliani the way they
present him this guy went from
winning the g-man award a few years ago
from fbi in 2015 to all of a sudden
i'm tearing down him or so
yeah i know i see it i'm just not the
whole story is a long story for me to go
through with
giuliani business with china right now
if china wanted to open you wouldn't so
if they said we're going to come in
we're going to make php the i wouldn't
do it
i wouldn't do it you know why i wouldn't
do it why why why would i ever do
something like that
i'm not a fan of control so what what
leverage do i have over you
let's just say i do that what leverage
do i have over you
what leverage the other day i'm trying
to pick up my uh global entry card from
tsa
you know how clear talks to me the
difference between buying a clear card
and tsa
you ready clear how are you mr david
good to see you
have you resigned and we'd love to get
your family on the program as well
thank you it's totally fine would you
like a mask oh we'd be more than happy
to help you out
you know how tsa i show up caroline
causes this woman just hung up on me
okay i'm driving down to tsa to get my
global entry card
why are you late why are you so late
what happened do you realize that i said
ma'am this is there's nobody here but
i'm sorry i'm late
i said ma'am i'm looking forward to
seeing you in five years when i renew i
will not be here intentionally
to never not ever deal with somebody
like you who is late i said i'm so sorry
so i left 100 bucks
100 bucks government doesn't give you
service you think i want to go in bed
with somebody that represents the
government
what are they going to do they're on my
team hell no what team are they going to
be on so i'm surprised where a lot of
these u.s companies want to do business
with china thinking they're going to be
on your team they're not going to be let
me pose you a question choose china
put yourself pat now
established has money money's not an
issue
pat 10 years ago just starting out
scraping by
yeah i don't maybe you i'm not saying
you but that person
don't disagree maybe by the way
considering by the way more than i don't
disagree this is why
this is why i i'm concerned
if a person who becomes president
doesn't have their own money
nor have they served in the military i
have a hard time with that yeah
i think a president have should their
own should have their own money because
you don't make any desperate moves
and you should have served in the
military those are my two criterias for
me
i think because who the hell are you to
tell a military guy what to do do you
realize how disrespectful it is to tell
them
miller you don't even know what life
they're living in you want to tell them
what to do
a soldier is going to sit there and say
what the hell are you talking about
what are you talking about like you want
to tell me what my life is like like
imagine if i tell you what it is to be
comedian
you guys are going to sit there and say
thomas you don't know what it is to be
comedian i've never been in that room
when comics are talking to
it's like me talking what's the big deal
about stealing jokes you're like what
the hell is the matter with you
yeah so to me you want to be a president
governor whatever
congress senate call forward you want to
be president you have to have your own
money
established your own money and number
two you have to have certain military
well look at trump he had his own money
but he didn't serve in the military
yeah and he's getting there telling
generals what to do i'm sorry there's a
difference you got if
you don't have it you can't talk to them
as if you know their world do you know
the only president to have
a family member serve in the military in
the last 50 years
bush no family relative a kid like a kid
one of their kids
is is biden no no i'm talking about
them them no i know i get it i'm saying
that but
you're saying you have no authority to
tell a general trust
you do not you don't yeah let me tell
you military is a very emotional
yeah these guys are talking about mental
uh you know health and all this stuff
by the way in the military yeah like
simone biles can take a break and go
become a hero for mental health and what
she did she has a choice to do that of
course
you can't do that in war you you cannot
do that when you're under that pressure
you cannot do that when you're firing
lines
you don't have the luxury to say hey
guys please stop shooting guys please
i have a headache i'm getting i'm
getting an attack anxiety a little
depression
let's please stop i'm gonna take a break
this is too much for me
please i'm asking you stop shooting okay
i'm gonna get up it's like you know how
you do a paint gun and guy gets up and
walks out guys guys guys
so so for a person to act like they
understand the military
or for a person who doesn't have money
for a person who doesn't have money to
be a president you scare me
yeah let me let me give you a different
perspective one of the things when we
when we hire c-suite executives you know
what i like to hear from c suite
executives i'll tell you one of the guys
who
expected a job here's how he recruited
himself look at the way he did it i
loved
his interview one of my favorites the
way he did it he says
uh i just want you to know i have a lot
of different options right now
uh for jobs because i'm very good at
what i do
and you can call my references of the
last 20 years and you will see what they
say
i work half days these are the kind of
hours i work i'm going to be here at
this time
i'm going to be at this time and my
schedule works this way
but i want you know i've had a lot of
different exits so financially i don't
need salary i don't care what you pay me
salary wise
you need to pay me a decent salary for
what the market tells me but i don't
want to be the highest paid salary guys
my interest is in equity i want you to
give me equity and give me a lot of
equity because that's what i want to
build i want to help build a company
because i've already had multiple seven
figure exits i have cash i have money i
don't need to worry about what i need to
do take care of my family for the rest
of my life
but i'm only here because the equity do
you know
i want him in leadership position
because he will never make a desperate
move nor will he ever give me feedback
because he's worried about finances now
flip it
i had another guy that came for a job
interview
a few years ago i'm doing the interview
with them this is one of the reasons why
i was scared about the haircut i was
getting yesterday
this is another interview i'm doing for
job this guy's also applying for c suite
job but this is five years ago six years
ago
so he comes in and the interview goes
resume
decorated decorated resume and he goes
through it
i want to be the cmo and i want to do
this i'm going to say no problem let's
go through the interview
so all of a sudden in the interview okay
first 10 minutes impressive second 10
minutes impressive third 10 minutes he
just says
man i gotta let you know what's been
happening with me this is my second
divorce and i just went through
this and i have to pay this much money
and i'm back on the rent if you can just
pay
in advance of twenty thousand dollars
for me to be able to do this and for me
to be able to do that and
while i'm moving this if you can throw
another ten thousand dollars in a minute
it'll be so amazing because of where i'm
at
you know what i sat there and i thought
about it i'm like oh i got to be careful
with this why
it's desperate because you and by the
way there's difference all of us have
been in a desperate position before
but not this is not even a talent thing
i don't worry about talent
this is an executive position an ex this
is very different with talent talent is
a different story
an executive position where you have to
lead people you can't be stressed out
about money
so i want to make sure household is good
i want to make sure finances are good
i want to make sure you've had the moral
authority to tell other people what to
do
so you want to be a president i would if
i was obviously i'm not the one that's
making the guidelines here
for me if you want to be a president i
think you got to have a net worth of
you got to have your wife your kids
covered your future retirement covered
if you got minimum 10 million
20 million okay great that's that's fine
but if you're in and you're only worth a
couple hundred thousand dollars you're
gonna do side deals for money because
you've never tasted money before
you've never tasted money before what if
you've made these 10 20 million dollars
in politics
no i don't like that yeah i don't like
that because to me
you again kai so to me there's two
things that you will never relate to
two things that you will never relate to
so for example let's put the one thing
that
men will never understand what is what
is the one having a baby we will never
understand what it is to have a baby
ever i've seen my wife we did
what she goes through with debate we are
never gonna understand that pain okay
that they go through now
so let's set that aside that's on the
pinnacle position for me at the top so
let's set that part aside we're never
gonna know no matter what we ever do
you're never gonna know so now let's go
to the other side a woman who was a
woman worth a half a billion she said
hey man can i tell you guys something
the closest thing you'll ever know about
what it is to raise a baby and have a
baby is to start a company and you're
the founder
only founders will know the closest
thing to the pain we go through having a
baby okay
if a politician has never ran a business
where he put his money on the line how
the hell do you know what it is to be a
small business owner
you don't know what it is to be a small
but you don't even know how scary it is
you don't know what it is to be a tax by
the way
when i was going through anxiety attacks
in 2013 2014
i couldn't tell the bank to stop asking
for payments i couldn't tell my
guy that i'm a release the two million
dollar contract on the office building
to give me six months to pay rent i
couldn't tell the guys
hey please guys don't put this i
couldn't tell my competitors stop trying
to approach some of our guys
i couldn't tell my carriers hey please
be a little bit nicer to us right now
because i'm going through mental
and anxiety i couldn't tell anybody
anything founders don't have that
ability
should you be able to should you be able
to call timeout no you you it's like the
war analogy it's not about
yes you should be able to but should
your competitors stop taking business
from you no
you should be able to do it but you
should also realize that you're going to
lose if you do that yes
no one's going to stop competing the
market's not going to stop competing
in this kind of a society so yeah i have
a little bit of a hard time
when somebody becomes a president who
one hasn't made the money
and two you've never served ah what
moral authority does it give you to tell
us what to do
yeah i think on the first point i mean
going wider on that is
human beings respond to incentives right
so
if you will really understand just how
the effect of incentives on people like
it explains so much behavior and so much
stuff and going back to what you were
talking about before with china is like
china can you know run this cold war
game etc like
you know china's been waging war without
firing any bullets or dropping any bombs
right because they understand incentives
so when they've got their tentacles in
hollywood in the nba
in sports in africa they're buying up
all this land and funding certain things
etc
they're not coming in with you know it's
it's not like threats and violence it's
not that old school we're gonna just
come in here with our guns and take
stuff over
it's no we've got a hand in every single
aspect we're in your political system
your entertainment your sports
everything
so i mean even this past year and a half
bro i mean dude you got people fighting
each other over this virus over masks
people were more mad people get more mad
about you saying the term chinese virus
or kung flu
yeah then they get mad about the fact
that china either
leaked or unleashed this thing out to
the world lied about it covered it up
for etc dude china's been back to normal
for
since like about may last year they won
how how
1.4 billion people epicenter of the rice
like they were distributing vaccines
spring last year
which vaccine how like if we had a real
media and real journalists that are
you know operating independently won't
they be asking like there's so many
there are so many questions here and i'm
just like wait we're arguing about all
this stuff i'm like can we go up a level
and be like wait what happened
they were allegedly the only country
that had a positive gdp
here's the big elephant in the room
you're talking about 4 000 deaths like
wait the big elephant in a room that
people aren't willing to talk about
china understands
our psyche better than we do and they
understand
uh look i'll just be real white women in
particular
they love authority bro they take to
authoritarianism these karens took to
authoritarianism
like ducks to water they found their
vein they found their person
they were like that's my target
demographic they found them
and they exploited the heck out of it
and they what they understood probably
they understand capitalism better than
we do
what is the number one advertising
demographic 18 and 39
females 18 and 30. so every if you own
the hearts and minds of those women you
own
every company trying to sell them
everything that's some deep [ __ ]
so china uh ccp is like
we're going out there karen bingo and
they're opening up this man they have
what they call it the 100 year plan
yeah right like it's it's not even like
we're coming up with conspiracy theories
or something it's like they're open
they're like look this is what we're
doing
in x amount of time we're gonna you know
have this we're gonna do this we're
gonna do that
and i look forward to a day when
conspiracy theorists start being wrong
again
oh no conspiracy theorists are just
spoiler alertness now
you guys are gonna be you guys are gonna
find this out in six months but yeah
this is what's actually happening some
really good points boys i gotta give you
respect
all right all good guys we are at that
time right now we've gone uh
after eleven seven minutes folks if you
enjoyed having zubion today smash that
thumbs up button and subscribe to the
channel
uh zoobee appreciate you for coming out
this was great just hear
your perspective thank you fantastic
real quick before we go pat
you gotta tell them what this this suit
is it's a three-day suit broker 99 bucks
you can get it
you know so but it is it's so just so
everybody knows here's some uh
good and bad news for you the good news
is uh
future looks bright everything's gonna
work out the bad news is we will not be
doing podcasts for i think two weeks i'm
gonna be out next week and i'm gonna be
out the following week uh we
changed this thing for friday to get
zubi on here we typically do these on
thursday
but within the next four weeks we will
be back on this doesn't mean you aren't
you're doing a podcast today sasuke yes
we'll be back on today we'll have things
that are going on well you'll hear about
a project i think we're announcing
possibly next tuesday that's going to be
massive next tuesday we'll be announcing
but outside of that we'll come back
again with the podcast stay tuned but if
you the vault is four weeks away
oh by the way yeah should i announce the
speaker
oh i'm about to announce the speaker he
is uh
he is don't say anything don't even
speculate i'm about to say
he is a number one ranked current
ufc fighter which we'll announce if you
want to find out who it is for the vault
text me at 310-340-1132-310-340-1132 one
more time
three one zero three four zero one one
three two
vault conference yeah what's the website
where can people sign up and learn more
about the ball
vault conference dot com the vault
conference dot com
if you text me at three one zero three
four zero one one three two we're gonna
give a special discount quote for the
first ten people that buy tickets on
today only on the text code
but you got to be on that text
distribution three one zero three four
zero one one three two
i'll be announcing who the speaker is
probably in the next hour or so so send
us a text
at three one zero three four zero one
one three two i feel like i'm on this
information guy
and if you call right now we will send
you a second set of knives
okay have a good one everybody take care
have a great weekend bye bye bye
you